yes sir i did have 32 hats i was ready
for anybody to pick me
and uh coach groom he definitely did
call me and
i'm in pensacola florida i'm on the
beach it's my hometown and i was
surrounded by my uh friends and family
and uh
i couldn't hang them more for being him
for being here and supporting me
and it was a great overall experience
and a great drive
because as far as being a leader that
was definitely one thing that i wanted
to change about myself going from my
junior to my senior year
just uh trying to affect those around me
you know what i mean in a positive way
and always harping on the things that we
needed to do to be champions and uh
i feel like that went well by the
results of my senior season
when we came out to national
championships
hey willie ramirez with the associated
press in las vegas we go back
two questions you had said that uh you
had all the hats waiting you were
waiting on on the call
that moment you received the call as
you're as you're watching the draft but
your name's not called there but you get
that call can you just maybe
take us a couple of things that were
said that that overall that overwhelming
feeling maybe the words that were said
to you
and just that exchange once you knew it
was official
i mean um to be honest uh it wasn't
really
overwhelming not that i wasn't excited
and extremely grateful
for the opportunity but um
you know i i controlled what i could
control you know what i mean so i was
ready for like any outcome i feel like i
did the best i could do
and when they called me and when they
called me i was calm
i was uh ready to go
as soon as i got a call i was like i
don't know who this is you know what i
mean but hey it's go
time you know what i mean so i was just
uh super grateful
elated at the opportunity and uh yeah
that's pretty much it
great thank you for your time alex
appreciate it congratulations well sir i
appreciate it